[MUSIC PLAYING]
My favorite programming
hack in Python
is that you can overload
functions with the at sign
by overriding its matrix
multiplication meta method.
I really like ternary operators.
I don't know why.
But every time I use one,
it makes me feel smart
and it makes my
code look elegant.
So I try to use them
wherever possible.
PDB, like the Python
debugger, and being
able to stop your program
state at any point in time
and then simulate
what could have
happened if you wrote
other code instead I think
is super useful.
Like, it makes deep
learning interactive.
Debugging is, like, fantastic.
This is more like
a library that's
very, very common in people
that use machine learning.
It's called TQDM.
It's very simple.
It's just a progress indicator.
But once you start using--
like training
these large models,
you'll just realize
just how useful
it is to have that little
progress bar showing you
how far your model has gone with
training and evaluation, too.
One powerful feature
of MatLab is that you
can use matrix operations.
So instead of working
with numbers individually,
you can put them in a
matrix, put them in vectors
and do processes
on them at once.
And it's really powerful
because this tool
is really optimized for working
with matrices really fast.
So you can get things
done much, much faster.
I don't know if
it's a hack or what,
but I can never remember which
way the matrices go in matrix
multiplication, right?
It's just-- you have
no idea what's going on
in a matrix multiplication.
And sometimes it's just
hard to think about.
So instead of
matrix multiplying,
you can use the Einstein
Summation Operator.
And this allows you
to explicitly state
what's going in to
the matrix multiply,
how it's combining on the axis
and how it gets summed up.
And a lot of people don't
like the Einstein Summation.
But I'm an Einstein
Summation zealot.
I use it all the time.
It saves me a ton
of mental overhead.
And I never have to remember how
the matrices fit together ever
again.